as many of you know the reason there are
two gill lectures this term
can be attributed to the difficult
weather of last january when
joel cotkin was unable to successfully
make his way to new england from
california
joel was able to reschedule his visit
east and he delivered his lecture on
october 20th
tonight kenneth frampton will deliver
the 31st
gill lecture the gill series was endowed
by san francisco architect
herbert mclaughlin yale college class of
1956 and yale school of architecture in
1958
the gill lectures series has a
distinguished
history bringing important critics and
historians to our school
previous guild lecturers have included
wendy steiner
esther de costa meyer david hickey
charles jenks roger connor and hal
foster this is professor frampton's
second gill lecture in spring of 2000 he
delivered the lecture
perspecta in the late 1960s the end of
the beginning
the diversity of the roster of gill
lecturers is
as it should be given that brendan gill
yale college class of 1936
was a writer with wide-ranging interests
who during a long career was associated
with the new yorker
magazine contributing drama criticism
and architecture criticism taking over
the skyline column
that had previously been lewis mumfords
tonight's lecture accompanies the
current exhibition in our gallery
gwathmi siegel inspiration and
transformation which is the first ever
comprehensive
uh exhibition of the work of gwathmi
siegel architects
inspiration and transformation was
organized by the cameron art museum
in wilmington north carolina where it
was on display from june 22nd 2009
through january 10 2010. the exhibition
was curated by douglas sprunt
adjunct curator of architecture and
design at the cameron
art museum who is with us here tonight
as is
robert siegel key partner um close
associate um uh and and a contributor
to the work in the gallery so we welcome
them both here
maybe they would just acknowledge
themselves with a wave of the hand so
bob siegel douglas brown
implant there are many people here also
from the glottamy siegel office and we
welcome them
one and all to the exhibition to the
talk and to yale
in planning the exhibition mr sprint
worked closely
with charles gwathamy who died in the
summer of 2009.
i thanked doug sprunt for his gracious
cooperation
in making it possible for us to have
this exhibition in our school
and i also take the opportunity to
welcome a great friend of our school
betty ann guathme who is also with us
here this evening betty ann
an illustrated catalog accompanies the
exhibition
with a wonderful essay by the
architectural historian stephen fox
of the rice university school of
architecture and interviews with the
architects
and selected clients charles gwathmey
was the only child
of the noted social realist painter
robert gwathmey
and rosalie guathme a respected
photographer
and member of the photo league charles
glothme first met his future partner
robert siegel
at the high school of music and art in
new york city
gwathmey studied architecture under
lukan at the university of pennsylvania
and went on to study and work under paul
rudolph here at yale
where upon graduating was awarded the
winchester traveling fellowship
the school's highest design prize as
well as a fulbright
grant that enabled him to travel to
france
and to visit the work of the corbusier
robert siegel
studied architecture at the pratt
institute and received a master's degree
from harvard school of architecture the
two
reconnected while working in the office
of edward larabee barnes
a key uh figure uh of architect
a practitioner and a great a man who had
a great working
staff in the 1960s and 70s
and has a tremendous influence on the
architecture of its own generation and
the succeeding generation
and then after leaving the barnes office
they founded their own practice
based on the success of the house and
studio
guathmy designed for his parents in
amagansen in new york between 1965 and
67.
one of the leading architects of his
generation charles gwathamy
was a brilliant talent who found his
artistic
artistic voice early on and kept to his
vision of what modern architecture
should be
through a lifetime of intense
professional practice
talented and content talent and a
continuing commitment
to a clearly defined set of aesthetic
principles
where is all marx as an architect he
embodied a ferocious integrity in both
his work
and his personal behavior he was a
friend to all of us who were lucky
enough to know him
but to the many architects who knew him
as
a mentor and a standard bearer for
excellence
he was even much more than that
from his student years on it was clear
to very many of his teachers fellow
students
and later fellow architects that charles
quoth me was one of the towering
talents of his generation while most
architects stumble along a professional
path
charles seemed to always know the way
after travel in europe and settling in
new york
working in ed barnes's office then the
top studio as i've said for young talent
charles soon embarked on his independent
career
which is of legend and history
charles not only designed those
structures for his parents
which electrified the profession but
also participated in their construction
this was no ad hoc do-it-yourself
project however
the rosalie and robert guathmay house
and studio were meticulously crafted
to the smallest detail moreover they
were dazzlingly composed
in relationship to each other and their
sight with
form and space entirely liberated from
the constraining biases
of the conflicted 1960s to incorporate
lost lessons from high modernism of the
20s
i am sure kendith brantrin will um
i hope you will agree with that
interpretation i'm always nervous about
that but i'm sure you will elaborate on
that
so i don't want to uh take your time um
further and analyzing charles's great
contributions to
the history of architecture but i do
want to say
that um uh uh the sense of a building
art
was central to charles gothamie's work
and when he and bob segal were hired
to do this project that is to restore
this building
and to add on to it and create the
glorious center for the history of art
next door
they threw themselves and their team
into it with intense
commitment and got this job done in 18
months from the moment
they were shocked to find that they had
been interviewed and 15 minutes later
hired by the university
and then told that was the good news but
the bad news was they had 18 months to
get the thing done
and they did so that is not only
artistic
but professional work at the highest
level
kenneth frampton's tonight's lecturer is
no stranger to our school
he has generously contributed his time
and talents to our studios
and to our various symposia professor
frampton ware professor of architecture
at columbia's school
of planning preservation architectural
planning and preservation
is a graduate of the architectural
association of london his publications
are essential reading
for those who wish to understand the
work and theories that characterize
modernism's complex history in the late
20th century
the architects who have benefited from
ken's monographic analysis
include modernist masters like record
mice
alfa alto as well as some of today's
most important talents
including david chipperfield who's with
us in the audience richard meyer
tadao ando alvaro caesar stephen hall
the hariri
and hariri partnership and charles
correa the name but a
few but it is to his widely admired
modern architecture a critical history
of 1992
that one must turn to get the full sense
of professor frampton's commitments
to the forms values and ideologies of
the modern movement
please join me in welcoming ken frampton
as he returns to our school's
podium to deliver the brendan gill
lecture gwathme siegel
form and counter form
not sure i have to give the lecture but
anyway
some of the ground has already been
covered uh thank you for that
very warm introduction and uh i'm very
honored to be here
and not a little uh
i would say somewhat nervous to be
giving
this lecture before such an august and
profoundly connected body
of uh figures that are that were part
and parcel of
grathamy's life above all betty ann
grafny robert siegel
and douglas sprung at the end of
towards the end of gratimi's life these
are the
two figures of course that are the main
principles of
uh grasping segal associates
appropriately shot against glass block
well
what i'm going to do this evening is to
read this paper but um
with sort of intervening in
informal comments
one cannot approach the work of grafmy
siegel without addressing the multiple
origins from which their work appears to
stem
i have in mind in the first instance the
american
balloon frame timber tradition as this
was transformed
by the immigrant bauhaus masters who
were warmly received by the modernizing
east coast elite as constituted in the
late
30s by such figures as alfred barr james
johnson sweeney
and above all joseph hudnut who was
responsible for bringing walter gropius
and marcelbra to the gsd at harvard
as we know there were other significant
bauhaus immigrants fed into the states
by a black mountain college yale
university and two
radical design institutions established
in chicago
mahogany's institute of design and
misses
faculty of architecture at iit
as far as the east coast is concerned
one has to acknowledge the exceptionally
seminal role
played by marcel breuer since it was it
was he
who seems to have been able to create
overnight an extraordinary sympathetic
modernizing manner with which he was
able to fuse the functional legacy of
the german
neues zachlike with the empirical white
claboted fieldstone domestic tradition
of new england
one of the first encounters when first
encountered this in gropius's own house
in lincoln massachusetts of 1937
and then later in the chamberlain
college
at chamberlin cottage designed for
breuer
by breuerfall for weyland massachusetts
in 1939.
that's still lincoln we see the
fieldstone in prominence at grade
and here the weyland cottage
this so-called new humanist manner a
coinage invented somewhat later by ian
nern of the architectural review
was in the end one of the primary
substrates so to speak from which
30 years later the incisive domestic
manner
of charles grasmi will eventually emerge
the catalyst in all of this was surely
the post-war american modernist
architect edward larabee barnes
who having studied at the gsd found a
way in his own work of translating
breuer's new humanism
into a sharper minimalist manner as we
find this in the houses he designed and
realized
between 1950 and 1971
in which out riding fieldstone walls
standing seam rules
light white board
tight white boarding or shingle siding
along with freestanding chimneys were
combined
with carefully proportioned fenestration
and pitched roofs
into precise abstract assemblies
typical of this work by barnes was the
cows house of 1962
the richter house 965
which is not that but that
and uh um and the heckshare houses in
maine
of 1974 which this is
a view of one of the houses they were
set up on a kind of
podium which we see here in plan linking
these different
separate units of the weekend
residents
both grafmi and his future partner
robert siegel worked for barnes during
this fertile period with siegel already
serving as
the straw boss so to speak of the
practice by 1963 which happened to
coincide with the time when groutmeat
joined the firm
gwathmi started to moonlight almost as
soon as he entered barnes's office much
to the latter's subsequent shock and
annoyance when gwasmi's
shingled miller house built on fire
islands in 1964
was published in the same issue of
progressive architecture alongside the
house by barnes
very diplomatic and
of course we can see here already in
this plan
something of the pinwheeling idea
that will finally as it were be
contained in a single
prism in the canonical amagunset house
designed and realized by grasmi for his
photographer mother and painter father
between 1963 and 65.
grasshomey's exceptionally touching
account of the way in which this house
came into being tells
us a great deal not only about the house
but also about the future ethos
and modus operandi of the grasme siegel
practice
i'm alluding to guatemala's possessive
attitude towards domestic design
as this was set down in the book
grasmere sequel houses published at the
millennium
i quote when my mother and i
bought the land in amagansit a one acre
flat field with views across the dunes
to the ocean and surrounded by
undeveloped land my mother said do what
you would do for yourself
just take our program and make believe
it's yours
that in fact is the way we do all our
houses we inherit the programs from the
client
we take the site we take the orientation
we take all the things that affect or
impact the opportunity
and we make it our own
in that way we become so integrated with
it
and emotionally part of the process that
it could never be detached or
automatic or repetitive each time it's
an invention
the chance to build this house for my
parents was an incredible opportunity
building it clarified for me that
architecture doesn't have to be big
to have presence or content that a
building as an object
on the land though small in this case
only 1200 square feet
can occupy a site with sculptural
monumentality
this house as in all our houses
is the is in
the section rather than the plan that
the primary space is defined
it is the volumetric manipulation and
vertical and the vertical rather than
the horizontal
description that articulates and defines
the space
the public spaces living dining and
kitchen one level above grade
capitalized on the views and established
a relationship
between the living space and the ground
plane that was at the time
unique in modern rural house
architecture
end quote i might note this adjective
rural
two features of this work which have
perhaps not been sufficiently
highlighted up to now is first the
absolute
canonical c character of the form making
it comparable to the
statue say of the reefer schroeder house
of 1924
or even look obviously maison cook
of 1926
and second the surreptitious homage it
pays
to pull rudolph out an architecture
building in yale from which gwasmi had
graduated under rudolf's effective
tutelage in 1962
this debt became clear at the time in a
photographic blow up of a greek relief
as this is superimposed on the balcony
front of the bedroom overlooking the
double height space
of the amagansett house i might point
out that this is
in this is the inside of the maison cook
where the
rotary action is and this question of
rotary versus frontality will come up
uh shortly but this of course is the
the photomontage homage our rudolph
inside the amagansett house
it was this house that propelled gwathme
into becoming a member of the new york
based five architects i'm alluding to
that familiar culture
that under peter eisenmann's leadership
shared the common credo that their
generation
had the responsibility of creating an
american architecture
capable of rivaling the compelling
achievements of the pre-war european
avant-garde
both formally and ideologically apart
from giuseppe terrandi and theo van der
sberg the primary referent
and inspiration for three of these
architects at least
michael graves richard meyer and grasmi
himself
was inducibly lucrabuzzier to which
grasmere's fulbright fellowship
notebooks of 62-63
amply testify uh
well this is a page from the sprint uh
publication and this which is a kind of
combination of
grasmere's notes about the modulo and
the house itself
and to some extent i think the modulo
was to varying degrees applied
particularly in the early work of
charles grasme
all of this will be confirmed by the
exhibition and seminar in title 5
architects held in the museum of modern
art
in 1966 for which both colin rowe and
myself wrote critical
texts alongside rose sophisticated
skepticism which would be fleshed out
much later in his essay
the architecture of good intentions i
wrote a more open
somewhat banal appraisal in which i saw
the work of the five as oscillating
somewhat
uneasily between the vestigial
classicism of frontality
and the dynamic spatiality of rotational
form
which in its turn you could say had
close links to the vernacular
and to the arts and crafts movement
these countervailing architectonic
tropes as first synthesized
uh uh in luke objects villagash of 1927
were to be returned to later in the work
of the five architects through the
conceptual
strategy stratagem of the 45 degree
axonometric as this format
pioneered by august schwarze and luca
buzier
was largely i think popularized in the
us
through the graphic representations of
james sterling's work who had exploited
this mode of projection in his early
houses
one of which is shown here or in his
design for churchill college cambridge
or in his projection of the
leicester engineering building of 1959.
notwithstanding the neo-baroque come
cubistic acts the metrics predicted by
graves in the mid-60s above all perhaps
in his
hanselmann house of six 1968
the most forceful exponent of this
rhetorical device was for a while
gwathmi himself
as this is undoubtedly undeniably
evident in the axonometric
of the american house where we have in
one in the same drawing
both the dynamic spatial party of the
house and the implied rotational
movement around its
form
one might note going backwards that
uh the graves house is but is both
partly frontal and rotational as opposed
to the uh peculiar rotational character
of the amagansett house
designed and detailed i believe in
collaboration with richard henderson who
was then
one of the partners or or momentarily a
partner
this singular neocorbusian work
took the form of a pinwheeling cubic
space form which as it happened was also
a graphic preoccupation in the cooper
union school of architecture at the time
under the leadership of john haydock
who had been appointed dean in 64 and
was the fifth member of the new york
five
while hiddock took pains to distance
himself from the neo-corbusian ethos
as was evident in his diamond show
what have i done with that lost it
yeah diamond show staged with
the painter robert slutsky in 1966
he nonetheless emphasized a comparable
axonometric presentation of the forms
once you note how the 45 degree skewing
of the
freestanding atelier in relation to the
house in amaganseet
would prompt the visitor to rotate
around the two cubic forms so as to view
the one
in terms of the other and vice versa
i think i should leave that there
this conjunction initiates the theme of
rotation in grasmere's domestic
architecture in that the rotation in
question
not only applies to the inner spatial
dynamic of the sculptural form
but also also to the way in which the
viewing subject is induced to
rotate around and through the work
while the spatial dynamic of the
american house is undoubtedly
neocobusin its archetectonic syntax
could hardly more
be more removed from the purest paradigm
in as much as in as uh look up he says
village of 927 was a totally frontalized
composition
the rotary spatial movement being
confined largely within
its interior this image perhaps doesn't
fully illustrate that point but as in
the maison cook
the energy is inside the cube and it
doesn't
emerge very much that is onto the
exterior of the building
the rotational synthesis of the
amagunsat house was the essential trope
from which the rest of grathamy's
domestic architecture unfolds
this synthesis merits further
examination since it puts gwathamy's
house into a class on its own when
compared to the houses realized by other
members of the new york five
grasmere conceived of the american house
as being carved out of a cubic block
and this aesthetic illusion was
sustained by the use of tongued and
grooved cedar balling
boarding as a continuous finish inside
and out
while he insisted that this materiality
was not a motive
he nonetheless concluded his later
retrospective
assessment of the house with the words
and i quote
within the limited budget a formal party
and vernacular
were developed that set a precedent for
the later work
thus craft me directly acknowledges that
the vernacular character came from the
flush jointed
narrow vertical boarding which he even
extended
to the soffits of ceilings irrespective
of whether they were flat or pitched
as far as the exterior was concerned it
was just this gray character
stemming from the way in which cedar
goes gray with age
which served to differentiate him from
the rest of the five
who were virtually committed one way or
another to the smooth
white finish inherited from the
international star
this was a conscious return to the
proverbial white architecture
particularly with respect to the work of
richard meyer whose language
was otherwise close to that of grasme
this ideological difference at the level
of exterior finish
may well have been due to the fact that
grasmere studied with lewis khan at penn
and with paul rudolph at yale without
depreciating the importance of
grasmere's dynamic plastic invention
this
pen yale background gave a particular
emphasis emphasis
to the expressive value of soundly
detailed construction
this preoccupation wasn't reinforced by
grasmere's post post-graduate internship
with barnes from
whom he seems to have assimilated a
particular poncho
for creating abstract minimal set pieces
be they domestic or otherwise in tightly
boarded construction
even though grasmere used this approach
to achieve a much more
concentrated rotational trope
the next four houses built by gwathmi
after his parents house
that is to say the strauss zendaka
goldberg and cooper residences that he
realized between 1966 and 1968
were all predicated on the manipulation
of equally of an equally compact cubic
party pre even though these formats pass
through distinctly different
permutations
as the architect tackles in each
instance a slightly different program
and a decidedly different site a more
open pinwheeling spatial configuration
bursting out of the confines of the
original cube
is most precisely decisively evident in
the cooper house
built in orlean orleans massachusetts in
1968 which i'm showing
here as image photograph and here
as an axon a metric of the way in which
these
semicircular bulbles forms
punch their way out of the cube
in the strauss residence on which he
collaborated once more with henderson
bold semicircular and quadrant forms
enliven an otherwise state orthogonal
two-story format the whole being unified
by twin monopitch roofs that cover
the breadth of the entire house
subtle formal spatial inflections serve
to animate the overall form by both
adding to and subtracting from the
volumetric point of departure
the 45 degree counter form that plays a
key role in the amagansett house
is reduced here to a mere quotation in
the
uh angled blade on the ground floor
where is that lost it
i've just lost it it seems all together
anyway all right
um
in the next grasmy henderson house the
saint said darker residents built in
east hampton in 1967
the virtual cube is more consistently
maintained as a reference with
a free-standing spiral stair situated
asymmetrically within a square plan
so as to animate the otherwise static
space form of the house
the three very simple moves impart a
liberative dynamic
to the overall volume this is the
freestanding chimney to which i will
refer
first the the provision of a raised
teres triangular
plan opening directly off the living
dining area second a full height plate
glass window wall which affords
ax axis visual and otherwise to the
terrace
and third an aerodynamically profiled
chimney shaft which
that closes the composition at the
corner of the terrace
in a kind of static response to the
spiral stair which
curves up from the living room to the
semi-circular mezzanine bedroom above
that's the spiral stair and by the way
here you can see i need to clearly
the boarded finish on the interior of
the
space
this in turn overlooks the double height
space as in the two previous houses
circular forms are played off against
an orthogonal matrix in this instance
a drum accommodates the entry while
housing the kitchen at grades in the
principal bedroom above the tubular
handrail of the spiral stair
seems to energize the entire composition
through its movement
once again narrow caesar boarding is
used as the primary facing material both
inside and out
as grassme wrote of the tight economic
constraints which drove this design
quote the materiality was also basic
formatter cabinets vinyl tile floors
electric heat
and cedar siding on the interior and
exterior the selection
of materials in these first houses which
i built as well as designed
and how they were detailed was
thoroughly considered even though
they look simple craft and longevity
were always
were always and have always been
pertinent obligations of the work
an elevated triangular terrorists would
also play a key role in the
orchestration of the goldberg house
completed in the on a woody site near
manchester connecticut in the same year
this is the goldberg house
in this instance the two-story format is
poised
at the crest of a hill down which is
subtly unfolds so as to culminate
in the aforementioned terrace on the
entrance side of the
of the the house appears as a single
story structure while
organized about a split level section
with the children's bedrooms being
situated half a level below
the main living floor and the master
bedroom suite being conversely
positioned half a level above
at this juncture in the evolution of his
houses
grassland began to move away from the
amagansett ideal typical of the domestic
work of the five who conceived
of the house as a freestanding aesthetic
object instead grass may
engended a whole series of houses in
which the expansive topographic aim was
to extend the centrifugal form of the
house
out into the surrounding landscape
either as an outrighting terrace
spinning off the centroid of the house
or as a timber passarelle
running off out into the dunes
this is the passerelle running off out
into the dunes
the amagansett party becomes greatly
expanded in the two steel
residences constructed in the same year
in bridgehampton new york
which we see here one of them and here
the other
in these twin resident residences built
for two generations of the same family
grafny plays with the idea of inflating
the previously subordinate cylindrical
elements to such an extent that they
plastically encompass
and overwhelm the basic orthogonal
format of the rest of the house
as we can see from these acts on the
metrics
the kogan residence competed in east
hampton in the same year will be the
first
of his residences to entirely abandon
the cubic party of the amagansett house
in favor of a horizontal mass form where
the major spaces
displaced by a half a level at each end
with respect to each other
are linked by a long ramp to the rear of
the main volumes
which face out over the pond
although grassme continued to represent
the dwelling with this habitual
cutaway axon metric one notes that this
representation
representational mode was now incapable
of embodying
the linearly layered spatial concept of
the house
both graphically and conceptually was
not possible to handle
the attenuated spatial composition
in the dynamic manner of the earlier
houses grasmere was only too aware of
the cultural consequences of this shift
in scale and complexity
when he wrote i quote
the kogan residence was our third large
house
the steelhouses built a year earlier
were extensions of the small
house ethic they were primary and
singular
larger versions of the carved eroded
volumetric forms
of the first series of houses we learned
that to simply
expand the vocabulary and parts of those
first small houses
to simply make them bigger was
problematic
extending the strategy lost the essence
the comp compositeness and the tension
the resulting houses were less dynamic
and less consolidated
in the cocan residence for the first
time the object building
with its articulated and small scale
representation
is combined with a large-scale
referential pavilion structure
the object building is thus locked into
the frame structure
and extends horizontally and vertically
through it
the counterpoint and juxtaposition
between these two elements
introduced an entirely different dynamic
and level
of enrichment into the work end quote
as we've already noted grosney was the
only one of the so-called white
architects whose domestic work
assumed a warner warmer and more
accessible tone
one which stemmed from his partial for
finishing the structure and vertical
cedar boarding
which melded to gray over time with this
warm tactile finish another
amber within and grey without grass me
was able to conjure up
a modern modus vivendi which appealed to
what was essentially an upwardly mobile
manhattan middle class
who has acquired a sophisticated taste
for a certain mid-century modern
modus of endi irrespective of whether
this took the form
of open plan vacation houses close to
the beach or gourmet dining in the
hamptons or fast cars or all these
attributes and pleasures together at
once
more than any of his contemporaries
guasmi had a feeling for the siberic way
of life
and thus has an innate sense of the
liberative context in which to fulfill
these sensuous aspirations
in this regard his plastically assertive
yet spatially liberative houses
while being totally free of nostalgia
were nonetheless able to convey a
feeling of domestic
warmth this ambience was greatly
enhanced by the furnishing of the houses
which were also often largely induced by
the architect
hence the prevalence in one house after
another of breuer's tubular steel chairs
along with luca musee's classic
tubular steel pieces
dating back to the salan's atom of 29
plus the b12 sunny bent with chair also
made famous by the swiss master
the built-in closets kitchens dining
tables chimney breasts and freestanding
cabinets which
possessed an inherently sculptural micro
spatial function
were invariably formed out of finely
veneered timber
or alternatively plastered or otherwise
finished
more cheaply in formica the warm
atmosphere of the hole might be
accentuated by
marimekko bed linings or the occasional
arctic chair by alto
or by a stellar print and and a
luxurious bed cover according to the
client's taste
and the mood of the moment although this
did not exactly produce a total work of
art it was nonetheless
a consciously cultivated high bourgeois
climate
much the same was obtained with the
richly orchestrated apartment interiors
that he created over the same
period which we first encounter
in the faye dunway apartment
built into the art deco carcass of the
el dorado building overlooking manhattan
central park
in 1969
here grasmere covered the floor of the
apartment with polished and waxed black
slate which he
which he furnished with me mr dining
chairs
in chromium tubular steel and wicker
a warmer feeling of sensuous luxus was
conveyed by the fur covered bed angled
towards the exterior terrace while
beyond
was an exceptionally capacious walk-in
closet
lined with built-in fittings this
labyrinthine yes well this of course
comes from the villa savoir
slightly different version this
labyrinthine retreat was
conceived as a sequence of action
settings
passing from a sculptural bathroom
ensuite behind the bed
to a sauna and separate shower attacked
inside the kitchen
on the other side of a substantial wall
and then i thought i would show you this
is the unga
apartment a series of these apartments
covering the 10 years i think more or
less between 75 and 85
this is the unger apartment
this i think is kitchen in the suite
apartment this is also swede apartment
this i think is the geffen apartment
these kind of episodic spatial valves
running throughout the interiors of
these apartments
i think are quite extraordinary this
is the orango apartment
very monumental using a blue stone which
i don't immediately recognize
and this is a plastic form in the
spielberg
apartment if i have it correctly and
this
is guatma's own apartment and this
is a pretty witty bathroom fitting in a
park avenue apartment unidentified and
this
is a well astonishing elaborate
two-story apartment built inside some
remarkable building and this is
somewhere in central park's house
as grasmi was to put it in in retrospect
in 2004
the design of of apartments involves
negotiating the inherent constraints
of existing conditions where the whether
planned configuration
ceiling height orientation views window
opening structure mechanical systems
plumbing or code restrictions these
constraints
rather than being limitations afford the
opportunity for a different type of
intervention
and innovation in its density complexity
and spatial definition
the composite cabinet furniture strategy
as we interpret
results in the creation of autonomous
objects that can be
read as miniature buildings end quote
it is difficult to overrate in
retrospect the exceptional beauty and
variety of these luxurious interiors
built a great expense for the new york
art collecting hollywood elite
grasmy seagull were able to indulge in
these micro spatial essays
in of poetic lexus and comfort without
having to take responsibility for the
exterior form
since this was de facto given from the
outset
frontality rather than rotation comes
into its own in gwasmi's work with the
berenson residents built in rye new york
in 1976
and in the taft and demoneel houses
built in cincinnati ohio
and east hampton long highland in 1977
and 79 respectively
this is the tough residence here
the tough residence effectively brings
guasmi's 20
year long involvement with neo purism
to a point of culmination in a large
complex broken into two distinct
different elements
we see this frontal element followed by
a kind of
tail at the rear
all three mass forms are linked by a
covered walkway at grade and the
passerelle above
while the main house and the guest wing
establish the confines of a large square
terrace at grade which serves as a
mutual open-air living space set before
a bucolic
prospect lined with trees
it's not so easy to read this from this
two features serve to extend the main
body of the house and impart a markedly
topographic character to the whole
a green sword which terminates in a haha
precisely
mirroring the width of the frontal
screen and secondly a pergola
covering the walkway between the car
court to the rear of the house and a
micro
mono pitch greenhouse set against the
northern boundary of the site
as and of course we see this elaborate
tennis court as grasmi has written
quote the tough residence on six and a
half acre
site overlooking the ohio river
consolidates
all the previously discovered strategies
instead of creating
a composite building here the program is
fragmented in response to the client's
desire
to not have despite excessive
requirements
a big house each of the programmatic
elements is distinctly articulated as
part of a larger building
site plan that extends the house
and defines a series of outdoor spaces
while engaging the landscape end quote
the diminishing house built in east
hampton in 1979
this is still actually taft at night
this is diminished site plan
elaborated on the frontal party of the
taft house
taking it a step further by establishing
a processional
route towards the front of the house
symptomatic of this general
aggrandizement are the
large areas of unshielded glazing
like the rest of the five grass me seems
to have had
little interest in any kind of
systematic sun control
moreover a virtually limitless budget
had the effect of dissipating the
dynamic spatial energy of grafmy's
earlier houses in my opinion
while the plastic orchestration of the
interior
still embodies something of the earlier
formal rhythm
the house as a whole tended to fragment
into into a somewhat
dissonant assembly of disaggregated
episodes
but this is no longer the demonial house
of all the independent professional
practices launched by the new york five
so to speak
there is little doubt that the
exceptionally prolific output achieved
by gwasmi siegel and associates
was the largest their record indicates
that during the first 20 years
of its existence
that is to say between 1964 and 1984
the firm designed and realized over 30
private houses plus
10 extensive university complexes
17 large office buildings and countless
domestic and commercial interiors not to
mention
a number of prominent museums including
their controversial 1982 extension
to frank lloyd wright's guggenheim in
new york
even if as of now one excludes the last
decade and a half of their production
it is obviously impossible in the space
of a single lecture to do any kind of
justice to such a diverse
and widely varying practice should go
back
which clearly involved not only the two
principles but also
countless assistance which grasme and
siegel went out of their way to
acknowledge
by name in their 20-year anniversary
publication
within this wide spectrum the case may
be made that the practice
was at its architectonic and social
sociocultural best
in the field of residential
accommodation
and while this is only too well known as
far as their high-end luxury production
is concerned
what has surely been insufficiently
recognized up to now
is the contribution that they made to
the field of low-rise high-density
housing
during the short-lived u.s social
housing boom of the 1970s
most particularly under the separate
patronage of ed logue
of the udc in new york and owen miller
acting for cummings diesel i believe in
columbus
indiana
in this regard i have in mind first the
whitney road housing that they realized
for udc in parent in new york
near rochester in 1972
but i but one should also not overlook
the student housing that they designed
for the state
university of purchase in 1973
shown here and
here in plan
along with the cooperative housing that
they projected for rest in virginia in
the same year
shown here and finally the sycamore
place
and pence street housing that they
designed for columbus indiana in 1978
in all these works they demonstrated an
unrivaled mastery
of economic unit planning and the
clustering of low-rise high-density
housing form
this is the whitney road housing
perinton
aside from the brilliant way in which
the whitney road housing was integrated
into the gently undulating landfall of
the
the most radical aspect of this udc
560 unit low-rise housing completed at
parenting in 75
was the subtly inventive manner in which
it was able to recast the 1934 radburn
planning principle in such a way as to
accommodate universal car ownership
the project description says everything
one needs to know about the play between
the two-story town houses
accessed from pedestrian courts and the
single-story apartment units
elevated one story above
covered walkways lining the four
internal cul-de-sacs
which provide convenient parking at hand
for both the houses
and the apartments i mean we're looking
here
at the houses but and we're looking here
you see these
four things yeah
these four arms that go down
to these uh housing clusters
and uh
and the yes and the the way in which
these housing clusters work in a
pedestrianized form and the way in which
the apartments are raised up
over the parking and continuous walkway
and here we see the walkway of course
and
and here you know continuous on the
perimeter a continuous
binding enclosing band of
two-story houses
and then there are these are absolutely
astonishingly
economical apartment plans which are
also a key aspect of their skill
i i'm i will read from the site
description of this
uh the office's site description the
description of the project the site
slopes from high points maybe i should
go back
to this image
the site slopes from high points on the
east and west
sides towards its center townhouses and
garden apartments
are located in four linear cul-de-sacs
each has its own parking area
and the units share
open space in semi-enclosed green areas
each family unit is provided with a
covered parking area the pedestrian
circulation
is designed so the pedestrians may walk
on covered walkways
and through green areas throughout the
site without coming into contact with
traffic
the apartments are located in the
southern portion of the site
with close access to the community
center
shopping and bus facilities the
townhouses serving larger families
are oriented towards the open grass
areas consisting of private
outdoor spaces the type of construction
is slab on grade prefabricated wood wall
panels
wood frame aluminium sash exterior
stucco interior drywall electric
baseboard heating this is one of the
courts
this is one of the open greensport
courts
of this scheme i wrote in 82
quoting myself at perrington grasmi and
siegel have succeeded in upgrading the
radburn concept so as to accommodate the
increased
density of automobile use in the last
quarter of the 20th century
at the same time they postulated their
housing pattern
which is opening open to a changing
sequence of readings as one passes
through different kinds of space
developed by the grid formation thus
while maintaining a certain scalar
relation to the suburban
context this pattern is much more urban
in feeling than rad burn
and this sense of abanity derives not
only from the store-like
perimeter walkways but also from the
pedestrian muse
or clusters which extend the layering of
the scheme in depth
thus parent and provides the the
alternative
of three different spatial experiences
the ability of the street
the labyrinthine quality of the muse and
the bucolic community
of the inner garden courts shown here
the cedar clubated timber frame sycamore
place housing built in columbus
indiana in 78 was equally adept at
relating a three-story staggered housing
cluster of eight apartments per floor
to a 14 unit entry car pocket grade
once again the description adequately
accounts for the social intention
and the ingeniousness of the invention
that
is brought to bear on its resolution
thus we read
this is the plans and you can see they
fit this description
the three-story step plan makes each
vertical row of three apartments
articulate identifiable and house-like
while acting to de-institutionalize the
building
the corridors become a sequence of rooms
with natural light and views at both
ends
by adding a balcony terrace to each
apartment the private space
is extended both physically and
psychologically
end quote
the unbuilt this is from the details of
the apartments i just described
the unbuilt alternating mono pitch
two-story pence street carpet housing
projected for columbus in the same year
attempted to apply the plastic syntax of
grossmi's ammo gunset house to multiple
two-story three-bedroom back-to-back
courtyard units accessed through
front yards via short walkways
extended into the fabric from integrated
parking
this is a work that in my view invites
comparison to sterling's
village infield housing prototype
exhibited in exxon provence
in 1955.
this brilliant prototypical piece of
low-rise high-density housing which
postulated nothing there less than a
normative economic form of motopian land
settlement would seem even now
30 years later to constitute a viable
and socially accessible alternative
to the support suburban sprawl by which
we are surrounded
bill to unbuilt these low-rise housing
schemes testified to a trajectory
in which the functionist hardline
inherited from the weimar republic
architects is transformed through
the new humanist vernacular of the east
coast
into socially accessible residential
land settlement patterns
that grasmere siegel proposed during the
heyday of u.s housing in the 70s
in this sector of their production
grasme siegel will come closer to the
social political cultural aims of the
interwar european avant-garde
than perhaps any other works projected
by the new york five
in making such sweeping evaluations we
should know
that what may be achieved by any
architectural practice at a given moment
in history
is largely determined by powerful
economic forces which although they
are somewhat off stage nonetheless shape
the degree to which
the socio-ecological fabric of the
environment
may or may not be rationally resolved
and maintained perhaps we pay
insufficient attention to the fact that
what any single architect may achieve
at any particular moment in time is very
much conditioned by the invisible forces
seemingly lying outside the constraints
of the period
the five architects were no more able to
return to the forms
and social programs of the pre-war
european avant-garde then they were
unable to create a truly compelling
civic architecture comparable to the
public works that were realized in the
states
after the catharsis of the american
civil war
i'm alluding to the re
received discourse of the echo de bozar
that prospered in this country during
the progressive era and which of course
in which of course most of the
institutions of the
post-civil war era were created
this is our condition for as martin
heidegger put it
so succinctly we are all each one of us
thrown
into history and what seems to be
possible in one era will not be possible
in the next
and so on it is clear for example that
despite our best efforts we cannot build
civic institutions with the same
conviction as the architects of the
progressive era
not only because we lack the
architectural syntax with which to do so
but also because we no longer believe
quite
in either the ideology or the efficacy
of these civic institutions and much the
same may be said for the panoramic
usonian vision of frank lloyd wright
who was totally convinced as the
manifest destiny of the states
and from whom significantly enough the
new york five including guatemala
maintained a scrupulous distance it's an
ironic fact that at the very end of
gwasmi's career
wright emerges as a ghostly protagonist
with whom he would be involved first
surely in the
in the addition to the guggenheim museum
and then again
via paul rudolph he would in
indirectly encounter him in the
restoration
and expansion of the art and
architecture building in yale
and i'm of course talking about this we
are sitting right in it
and but i'm also talking about this
which is a section through the
restored building and the addition
and i'm also talking about this
because it's it's my belief that this
building ultimately has
as its point of departure writes
larkin building in buffalo of 1904
significantly what had been separately
possible for wright
and rudolph namely the creation of a
convincing micro cosmos
would prove somewhat elusive for gwathmi
at the end of his career
as we may tell from a retrospective
comment he made
towards the end of his life grasmi's
restoration addition to paul rudolph's
art and architecture building in yale
brought him to confront the uncanny
interplay between individual fate
tradition and history for here via
rudolph
grasmi had to come face to face with
that
aspect of the american vein that
ultimately stemmed
from the eustonian spirit of right
one has the sense that gratman was only
too aware
that this leviathan of a building
had been inspired by rats like larkin
building
and here i would like to argue that it
was no more possible
to add in a convincing manner to such a
self-contained
vision as rights guggenheim as it would
be to
add to the equally
introspective uh neo-roti
neo writing and art and architecture
building in yale
particularly with when one was reduced
to using
a lightweight membracious syntax derived
from the discourse of the interwar
european avant-garde
and here perhaps we have some inkling of
the sheer force of traditional history
which while
assuming an architectural form is it uh
in fact transcends architecture in as
much as it depends on
on it uh
for its fulfillment on a belief system
which derives from the society as a
whole
i mean i think this is a historic nexus
here where the rudolph building faces
off
khan's art yale art gallery
with the other canyon museum down the
street
here perhaps we can have some inkling of
the sheer force of tradition and history
which while assuming
an architectural form in fact transcends
architecture in as much as it depends
on an entire belief system deriving from
the society as a whole
it is my contention that here in the
very heart of the yale campus
at the fatal intersection as it were
between rudolf khan and gwasmi
and then by proxy via rudolph wright
we are witness at the level of belief
with an incipient knowing
loss of faith in the progressive
historical destiny of the united states
i would like to put it to you in lieu of
a conclusion
that culture and tradition act in
society in a given moment in
disconcertingly uncanny ways
and what is feasible believable one
might say at one moment in history
is neither credible nor possible in
another
and in the case of grasme set before the
mammoth challenge of the art and
architecture building
excuse me this impossibility
became in my view doubly intractable
in as much as he was caught between two
anti-antithetical tectonic traditions
neither of which could be convincingly
continued that is to say on the one hand
the abstract part theosophical parts
socialist utopian socialist
discourse of the european avant-garde
circa 1920 1939
and on the other the romantic eustonian
vision of right
that singular american heritage that in
the midst
of the post-war pax americana the new
york five elected to reject
wright patently believed like louis
sullivan before him that it was possible
for the united states to create a
monumental
architectural culture rivaling not only
the morrow band classicism of europe and
the echo de bozar
but also the monumentally heroic
civilizations of the ancient world
the trans-historical challenges that
were lying within the traditions of
mesopotamia
egypt and greece and surely the fact is
that rudolph while not in any way
directly
imitating the language of right
nonetheless evidently
entertain comparable romantic
convictions this surely is the
significance of the statue of minerva
rising up
in the heart of the building at the
moment of its completion
along with the colored plaster cast
reliefs from the ancient world that
surreptitiously
and mysteriously line the staircase and
ancillary rooms of this historic
concrete monolith although grasmi was
not inclined
to comment on this tectonic unconscious
so to speak
he acknowledges nonetheless the
masterwork status of the building
as he would as he was to put it about
the critical feedback he had already
received
in his interview with douglas brunt and
i quote
it's been pretty brutal they've
rediscovered rudolph for which
i'm happy i think restoring rudolph's
building
adds to the modern architectural legacy
and it should be acknowledged as an
important work
it's a masterwork but at the same time i
think our building is incredibly
sensitive
deferential and enriching to his
building
nobody actually understood the program
of our building and how we maintain
rudolf's courtyard idea and how the roof
skate
is a reinterpretation of the courtyard
and how we maintained
the views from the studios and actually
added the dynamic that you're in
architecture
looking at architecture they're
confronting each other each other
having a dialogue so far all
that people see is the facade i have to
say that the majority of press critics
most of whom are failed
literature architecture or history
majors
self-arbiters without retribution
were unfair and grasmi goes on
to further to actually use the word
mean spirit and my only hope
is at the end of this discussions that
you will not
think that on balance i have been unfair
or at the very least mean spirited thank
you
i think i i speak for all of us when to
say that kenneth's uh
assessment of charles's work is
comprehensive
uh and uh thoughtful in the extreme it
opens up beyond what we have in the
gallery
uh the full spectrum of the practice
uh which was so important uh for so
many of us and also for the history of
architecture so we
uh i applaud that great piece of work
and it was not mean-spirited
at all we have questions i don't know if
it's appropriate at this moment but if
there are any burning questions
i suppose we can entertain them we have
a little time
is there anyone who wishes to um
ask our speaker anything
uh i guess you've answered all the
questions
well um there's always an opportunity to
ask a question over a drink
in the gallery on the second floor where
you can
enjoy each other's company and the
marvelous work
of guathmee siegel thank you very much